et on continue de parler de la réforme
de retraites avec notre invité g8 alidou
élus cgt cheminots bonjour monsieur de
l'edough merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors la ratp appellent à une
journée morte et apparemment voilà il ya
des transports qui sont perturbés mais
rien de similaire à ce que l'on a pu
voir précédemment avec voilà un
mouvement suivi à près de 90% est ce
qu'aujourd'hui le mouvement s'essouffle
justement à la ratp la sncf il
s'essouffle et naturellement dans le
sens où les travailleurs sont étouffe
ont été étouffés financièrement
en fait le mouvement s'est calmée pas
sur une base se passe
les travailleurs sont pas rangés entré
chez eux parce qu'ils n'étaient plus
d'accord avec le mouvement lui-même
l'essence du mouvement qui s'orientait
contre cette retraite à points c'est
tout simplement bon il faut être
rationnel
la vie est difficile pour tout le monde
il ya des factures à payer ou une maman
bail
on peut plus peuple tu es donc il ya
toujours des résistants il ya des poches
de résistance et toujours des camarades
conscience sur le terrain il ya toujours
des militants des travailleurs sur le
terrain qui vont jusqu'au bout et qui
ont le courage d'aller jusqu'au bout
effectivement mais financièrement c'est
très difficile donc on pourrait en fait
voilà le mouvement ne pourra jamais
atteindre ce qu'ils disent qu'il était
le 5 décembre puisque je sais que au
sein justement du syndicat cheminot on
essaie de tout mettre en oeuvre pour la
mobiliser le plus grand nombre
en tout cas en ce qui nous concerne la
cgt cheminots on a clairement continuer
prolonger le préavis de grève vraie vie
greffe chez nous il est prolongé
jusqu'au jusqu'au mois de juin 2020 donc
il est toujours d'actualité mais là on
sait que certaines certaines
organisations amies comme sud rail
notamment aussi ont prolongé leur
préavis grève
maintenant on espère on continue notre
travail de conscientisation notre
travail de conscientisation des sur le
terrain et il faut voir dans les
semaines qui vont venir on espère qu'il
y ait une heure et amorce de la lutte et
surtout surtout aussi des continue le
développement de cette convergence qui
avait été commencé avec le mouvement des
gilet jaune
bogui que ce mouvement contre les
retraites à points à converger il ya
quelque temps avec le mouvement des
gilet jaune et mais on sait aussi que la
convergence si vous voulez la
convergence ça se fait pas on a tendance
à dans une vision assez vision de cette
convergence qui est assez
limité à dire ces anneaux c'est la
convergence ça n'est pas seulement au
niveau spatial ce convergé dans la rue
c'est bien mais au niveau des idées là
c'est plus complexe et il faut converger
au niveau des idées ça ça prendre plus
de temps il faut le temps de le faire et
il faut aussi que certains médias
prennent leur responsabilité alors on
sait que les débats vont commencer donc
à l'assemblée aujourd'hui autour de
cette réforme des retraites est ce que
vous avez assoupli vos revendications
est ce qu'elles sont toujours les mêmes
vous demander le retrait intégral du
texte toujours en en ce moment retrait
en demande le retrait intégral
même si bon bah il faut être rationnel
tête le texte est présenté aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée
donc il va sûrement passé ils ont le le
gouvernement l'a porté depuis les tous
les gouvernements d'ailleurs
jusqu'aujourd'hui l'ont porté
aujourd'hui ils vont présenter le texte
ils vont certainement pas voté contre
mais en tout cas il ya deux choses
on demande toujours le retrait c'est une
position de principe mais de plus les
revendications ont été posées et qu'est
ce qu'on a proposé parce que finalement
on a fait des propositions mais c'est
pas des propositions idéaliste
irrationnel qu'est ce qu'on a proposé
augmentation des salaires d'une manière
générale pourquoi parce que augmentation
des salaires
si vous augmentez les salaires vont
augmenter les cotisations sociales si on
augmentait cotisations sociales on
augmente les possibilités de financement
plus précisément le salaire des femmes
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
femmes touchent 20 % à peu près 20% en
moins que les hommes en augmentant le
salaire des femmes ça apporterait une
augmentation de pareil sur un principe
augmentation des cotisations sociales et
d'une manière générale ça va augmenter à
peu près entre 6 et 10 milliards d'euros
par an qu'est ce qu'on a dit à la cgt
le cor conseil d'orientation des
retraites nous a dit qu'il fallait
atteindre pour attendre de l'équilibré
budgétaire
il fallait trouver un peu près 20
milliards d'ici à 2025
l'équation est simple aveu un prolétaire
peut faire l'équation a besoin d'être
sorti des rangs des grandes écoles
bourgeoise pour la faire augmentation
des salaires 10 milliards d'euros par an
on revient sur les suppressions
d'exonérations les
une exonération pardon de cotisations
patronales vial cse etc qui ont donné en
cadeau monopoles capitalistes plus de 50
milliards d'euros
on revient sur le fric qui est caché
dans la perdit fiscaux l'addition est
facile safex en plus 50 ça fait 150 ans
shop 170 milliards alors on sait qu'il
ya plusieurs amendements qui ont été
déposés les députés n'ont pas eu le
temps justement de voir tous les
amendements qui ont été déposés puisque
il était au delà de vingt mille
amendements aujourd'hui voilà certaines
voix disent que le président risquent
d'avoir recours aux 49 3 pour faire
passer en force ce projet de loi quelle
sera la situation si jamais ça se passe
comme ça
l'ati cela ça va être simple en fait ce
qui va se passer c'est que alors là où
aujourd'hui la réforme la retraite à
points va passer s'ils utilisaient 49,3
et cetera ils vont là elle va pas passer
dans des conditions et elle va passer
dans des conditions particulièrement
complexes pourquoi parce que
actuellement le mode de production
capitaliste est en crise le mode il faut
dire les choses franchement
le mode de production capitaliste donc
est en crise crise politique crise
institutionnelle crise environnementale
aggravation des conditions de vie et de
travail du peuple travailleur
on l'a vu avec le mouvement des gilet
jaune l'a vu avec ce mouvement là donc
ils vont faire passer une réforme une
retraite à points envers et contre tous
dansé conte 2 par ces conditions
objectives de parent c'est conditions
qui s'aggrave
ils vont la faire passer en force en
réalité ils vont aggraver la crise
révolutionnaire
ils ont fluidifié le développement des
idées révolutionnaires juste rester
vraiment un appel juste 30 secondes
quand je voulais juste faire un appel
parce que un appel à la gauche de la
gauche
pourquoi parce que c'est important de
2,2 de noms des eaux calmes à de la
gauche de la gauche de prendre leurs
responsabilités
que ce soit les trotskistes que ce soit
c'est les anarchistes que ce soit les
maoïstes
il faut qu on converge dans la lutte
dans un front uni pour le plus le
travail très bien tout cas merci
beaucoup agi me daligou d'avoir répondu
à ma question je rappelle que vous êtes
élue cgt cheminots